[Musik]
Eskalation im Nahen Osten in der Nacht
attackiert die palästinensische
Terrorgruppe Hamas Israel mit tausenden
Raketen bewaffnete Kämpfer überwinden
die massiv geschützte Grenze vom
Gazastreifen sie töten und entführen
dutzende israelische Zivilisten und
Soldaten Israel schlägt mit der
Militäroperation eiserne Schwerter
zurück den ganzen Tag über gibt es
schwere Kämpfe die Luftwaffe beschießt
Ziele im Gazastreifen Außenministerin
Annalena berbock verurteilt den Angriff
aufs
schärfste der Terror der Hamas muss
sofort
aufhören die deutsche Bundesregierung
steht solidarisch an der Seite
Israels israel hat das völkerrechtlich
verbriefte Recht sich gegen diesen
perfiden Terror zu
verteidigen das ist der Tag der größten
Schlacht so nennt ein hochrangiger
hamaskommandeur was seine Kämpfer in den
Morgenstunden begonnen haben Raketen
Schusswechsel geiselnamen schon jetzt
ist klar der naheosten erlebt ja
erleidet die schwerste
Auseinandersetzung seit Jahren warum
ausgerechnet jetzt was hat dazu geführt
und wer könnte das Blutvergießen beenden
das wollen wir ausloten in diesem ZDF
Spezial zu ich Sie sehr herzlich begrüße
wieder also herrschen Gewalt und Terror
in und um Gaza diesen Küstenstreifen der
zu den am dichtesten besiedelten Flächen
der Erde gehört fast 2 Millionen
Menschen leben dort unter größtenteils
ärmlichen Bedingungen es ist die
Machtbasis ja das Machtzentrum der
radikalislamischen
Hamas seit 2007 beherrscht die
Terrororganisation den Gazastreifen
schürt den Hass auf Israel und treibt i
nun einem neuen blutigen Tiefpunkt zu
Nikola albricht fastst
zusammen es beginnt am frühen Morgen die
radikale Hamas die den Gazastreifen
regiert feuert in einem
Überraschungsangriff tausende Raketen
auf Israel zu viele in zu kurzer Zeit
das Raketenabwehrsystem irondome kann
sie nicht alle
abfangen es war eine massive Explosion
ich habe ein Kind schreien hören ich
weiß auch nicht wir leben in einer
Realität die so surreal ist
ein Horrorszenario das Israels
Bevölkerung seit Jahren kennt immer
wieder kommt es zu militärischen
Auseinandersetzungen zwischen Hamas und
Israel doch dann geschieht zeitgleich
was so noch nie passiert ist zahlreiche
bewaffnete Kämpfer der Hamas dringen aus
dem eigentlich durch eine Sperranlage
streng abgeriegelten und überwachten
Gazastreifen auf israelischen Boden vor
handyvos von israelischen Bürgern zeigen
wie sie sich Schusswechsel mit Polizei
und Armee liefern sie dringen in Häuser
ein töten Zivilisten auf der Straße
Bilder zum Teil zu grausam als dass wir
sie hier zeigen könnten israelspremier
Benjamin Netanyahu ruft das
Sicherheitskabinett zusammen und den
Kriegszustand
aus seit heute morgen ist der Staat
Israel im Krieg unser erstes Ziel ist es
die feindlichen Kräfte auf unserem Boden
zu eliminieren und Sicherheit in den
Ortschaften
wiederherzustellen Israels
Militärführung beruft unterdessen
ztausende Reservisten ein die Armee
beginnt Luft Angriffe auf den
Gazastreifen zu fliegen von dort melden
palästinensische Behörden rund 200 Tote
in einer seltenen propagandaansprache
wendet sich der Militärchef der Hamas an
die
Öffentlichkeit wir haben beschlossen den
israelischen Verbrechen mit Gottes Hilfe
ein Ende zu setzen damit der Feind
begreift dass die Zeit in der er Unheil
anrichten kann ohne zur Rechenschaft
gezogen zu werden vorbei ist die
Menschen in Gaza flüchten derweil vor
den Bomben aber es gibt auch
Unterstützung für die hamasführung
nein nein ich habe keine Angst ruft
diese Frau dem Reporter zu wir werden
alle sterben irgendwann aber vorher
hoffentlich
Siegen unterdessen setzt sich der
Albtraum für die israelische Bevölkerung
fort wie Schlachtfelder sehen einige
israelische Ortschaften aus mehr als 100
Tote zählen Sie bis jetzt verzweifelt
die Überlebenden immer mehr Videos
zeigen wie lebende und getötete
israelische Bürger in den Gazastreifen
verschleppt werden heute
ein jüdischer Feiertag der mit einem
unerwarteten Angriff startet und dann
Tod und Zerstörung bringt wie vor 50
Jahren als der jomkipur Krieg anfing und
es ist nicht vorbei mehrere hundert
Kämpfer der Hamas sollen noch auf
israelischem Boden
sein ja und aus Berlin ist uns der
israelische Botschafter in Deutschland
Ron prosor zugeschaltet guten Abend der
Botschafter guten Abend ein düsterer Tag
für Israel ja letztlich für alle
Menschen die unmittel von der
neuerlichen Gewalteskalation betroffen
sind was empfinden Sie persönlich in
diesen
Stunden ich werde es anderes bezeichnen
das
sind Hamas terroristische Organisation
die wirklich israelische zivilisisten
ohne
wirklich zu denken ob es Frauen Kinder
Männer sind auf die
Straßen schießen als wir jetzt
sprechen sind noch kibuzim dürfe und
Städte in Isel noch nicht
befreit Leute werden wurden als Geisel
genommen und was mich wirklich und ich
glaube dass
alle dazu ein bisschen nachzudenken
bringen soll ist wie sie tanzen wie sie
jubeln wie sie über die Leichen und die
zivilisisten die ermordet worden sind
wirklich als ob es diese jubeln ist für
uns alle und die
hamasführung die soll die Verantwortung
nehmen weil jetzt was vorkommt ist
natürlich ganz klar ein Preis dass sie
bezahlen werden für die Tatsache dass
die Kriege in Israel angefangen haben
ihr Premierminister der Regierungschef
netano spricht ja davon Israel befinde
sich im Krieg mit der Hamas was bedeutet
das konkret worauf müssen sich ihre
Landsleute aber auch die Palästinenser
im Gazastreifen jetzt einstellen erstmal
ist es klar wir sind äh jetzt als wir
sprechen im Krieg die Anzahl der Tote
und Verletzte steigt und äh was das
heißt das heißt äh dass äh diejenigen
die Israel aus Hamas angegriffen haben
werden einen hohen Preis bezahlen und äh
denken Sie mal nach die Führung von
Hamas denk nicht über die Wohlstand der
Palästinenser in Gaza äh mehr als 2500
Raketen Terror auf die Straßen Israels
äh und das aus unserer ganz klar wird
ein Preis die werden ein Preis bezahlen
und diese Abschreckung soll so stark
sein dass nie wieder jemand in diese
hamasführung die sollen zwei oder
dreimal darüber nachden
ob sie das wiederun ja sie sagen was
wird ein Preis für bezahlen es gibt ja
auch Berichte über geiselnamen über
entführte und verschleppte israeliserlin
50 in einem kibutz wie weit wird denn
ihre Regierung gehen um diese Menschen
zu befreien die werden wie jede andere
Regierung ein demokratis Staat alles tun
um unsere Bevölkerung zu verteidigen und
diejenigen die als Geisel genommen
worden und auch anderen die werden alles
tun um die zu befreien aber die sie
müssen ganz klar und all diejenigen die
in der Vergangenheit immer gesagt ja und
sie benutzen auch diesen Begriff
militanten oder Kämpfer das sind kein
das sind Terroristen und die Art und
Weise wie sie arbeiten kann man jetzt
mal sehen und diejenigen die es noch
nicht verstanden haben hoffentlich
werden es jetzt verstehen ganz klar ein
Preis sie werden einen hohen Preis dafür
bezahlen und die Bevölkerung in Gaza
ihre Führung als Verantwortung sehen und
ich hoffe dass in den letzten nächsten
Tagen und Wochen dass das jetzt
weitergemacht wird dass die nicht wieder
die erobere Zeigefinger gegenüber Israel
wir wurden angegriffen und provovoziert
einseitig und wir können wie jeder
andere demokratische Staat das nicht
zulassen ganz klare Worte des
israelischen Botschafters in Deutschland
rund ich danke Ihnen für das Gespräch an
diesem ihren Tag vielen Dank nach Berlin
danke
Ihnen ja bleibt die Frage warum der
jahrzehntelange Konflikt zwischen Israel
und den Palästinensern gerade jetzt
wieder eskaliert und womöglich in einen
neuen Krieg mündet fragen wir dazu den
nostexperten Daniel Gerlach guten Abend
nach Berlin ja guten Abend Herr geril
haben sie eine Erklärung dafür warum die
Hamas gerade heute zugeschlagen hat ein
sehr symbolisches Datum heute es ist
einmal ein hoher jüdischer Feiertag es
ist Schabbat und es ist der Tag nach dem
50 jahrestag des jomkipur Kriegs vor 50
Jahren als die arabischen Nachbarn
Israels in einem Überraschungsangriff
Israel weit zurückgedrängt haben und das
israelische Sicherheitsempfinden sehr
empfindlich beschädigt haben heute sagen
viele in Israel das sei so eine Art 11
September den man dort erlebt also ein
unvorhersehbares und auch
unvergleichliches
sicherheitschaos aber ich denke es ist
sehr gut beschrieben was diese Situation
bedeutet wenn man sich den Grad der
Alarmstufe anschaut ähm es wurden ich
glaube erst zum zweiten Mal in den
letzten 50 Jahren sämtliche Reservisten
zu einem unbestimmten zeitlich
unbeschränkten Einsatz eingerufen das
nennen die israelischen Streitkräfte die
Order Nummer 8 und wenn man sich das vor
Augen hält dann dann sieht man dass die
Israelis das offensichtlich sehr sehr
ernstnehmen und nicht nur geschockt sind
sondern eben auch bereit sind jetzt
einen Krieg zu führen so wie es die
Regierung angekündigt hat also
raketenbeschluss aus dem gasastrafen
heraus gab es auch in den vergangenen
Jahren aber jetzt hören wir von
bewaffneten Kämpfern die ja nach Israel
eingedrungen sind die Ortschaften nach
wie vor regelrecht ja erobert haben und
immer noch halten obwohl das Militär die
Grenzen zu Gaza streng bewacht wie
konnte denn der Hamas ein solcher Schlag
überhaupt gelingen das kann ich ihn
natürlich so nicht sagen ich wundere
mich selber darüber dass es
israelische Serienproduzenten und
Drehbuchautoren gibt die solche
Szenarien vorausgesehen haben aber
möglicherweise die israelischen
Nachrichtendienste und Militärs nicht
die Hamas trifft Israel gerade in einer
Situation großer Inter innerer
Unsicherheit auch es gibt ja wie Sie
wissen starke innenpolitische Konflikte
es gab sogar Reservisten die angekündigt
haben dass sie der Regierung Netanyahu
nicht mehr folgen wollen wenn Sie den
einberufen werden ich glaube das ist
jetzt hinfällig das werden sie trotzdem
tun aber Israel hat auch eine Führung
die eigentlich mit Netanyahu nicht
besonders kriegsorientiert ist aber
zunehmend sich radikalisiert hat und von
Politikern bestimmt wird die den nicht
nur den Ton sondern auch die Aktion
gegen die Palästinenser in den letzten
Monaten stark verschärft haben und die
palästin und die Hamas möchte sich eben
jetzt darstellen als die Kraft die sich
an die sperspitze des palästinensischen
Widerstandes setzt und sie benutzt dafür
niederschwellige technologische
Instrumente und zeigt dass sie die
israelische hochtechnolog
technologisierte Armee eben nicht aus
der Kraft setzen kann aber sehr
empfindlich beschädigen kann mit
manuellen Mitteln auch wenn jetzt alles
nach Eskalation aussieht bleibt die
Frage nach einem möglichen Ausweg gibt
es denn aus ihrer Sicht überhaupt mit
der Bitte um eine kurze Antwort eine ja
anerkannte Größe die jetzt in dieser
Situation erfolgreich vermitteln könnte
bisher sind es vor allem Ägypten und und
Qatar gewesen die vermittelt haben und
ich denke mal die ter sind nach wie vor
auch bereit von den qataris hört man
allerdings große Frustration sie rechnen
nicht damit dass sie bald eine
vermittlungssituation erleben werden und
vor allem fragen sie sich eben auch was
können Sie anbieten sie sehen eine
Radikalisierung auf allen Seiten sie
sehen keine Kompromissbereitschaft und
irgendwann macht man sie Rotz Vermittler
dann unglaubwürdig die Sicht des na
ostexperten Daniel Gerach danke nach
Berlin danke
Ihnen ja so viele Tote so viele
Verletzte wieder brennt der Nahe Osten
wieder scheint der Hass mächtiger als
der Wille zum Frieden zur Koexistenz
stattdessen dreht sich einmal mehr die
Spirale von Gewalt und gegenewalt die
leidragenden leben ja auf beiden Seiten
des stacheldrahts jene die keine Uniform
tragen sie darf die Welt heute nicht
übersehen das war unser ZDF Spezial
danke für Ihr Interesse und auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen